hey what's up everybody i got a new
video for you guys showing you guys how
to program
i'm going to be programming adding
another key to the mdx
this will also work for the tlx the rlx
the mdx and other models
uh mdxs i'm going to show you guys how
to program it
from the x tool
easy 400 pro this is i'm going to put a
link down the video description to this
tool
this will program wireless keys as i
said in my last video
i'll link the video showing more about
this scan tool um
in the description and uh at the end of
the video
so what i'm gonna do right now is a
program key this is the key i'll be
programming it's a blacked out key
with the acura logo on the back so i'll
be programming this one
to the car so it'll lock and unlock the
doors and it will start the vehicle
just like the original one okay
so right now i'm going to go to
immobilization
and this one has lifetime updates so
this will con
keep getting updates for the life that
you have it
which is amazing so i'm going to acura
then i'll go to smart key system
then this would be the three button
smart key system
okay so then they have add smart key and
all smart keys lost we're not going to
do all smart keys laws because
we don't want to erase the keys that are
already there so basically what i'm
going to do now
is click on add a smart key okay double
click on whether the ignition can be
switched on so basically what this would
do is
this would force start the car in case
you lost all your keys
for this vehicle it can force start the
car on if you hit
um no it'll force start the car on and
then the ignition will come on
just so you can be able to program the
vehicle to the ignition
i mean to the car so i'm gonna double
click
because it can turn on which is this
you'll see this on the dash
showing that it's on okay so it says
double click on the start button
yes the ignition turns on so now it's
communicating with it
said take all smart keys out of the car
so that's what i'm going to do
i'm going to take this key and move it
far away from the car
[Applause]
okay so now i put the smart keys real
far away from the car about 10 to 12
feet away
so now i'm gonna hit okay it says put
one program
smart key in the car so i'm gonna get
the program smart key
give me one second okay so now i have
is in the car now the system is
configuring
it says take the smart key out of the
car okay
so now i'm going to take this one out of
the car and put it to the side about 12
to 15 feet away
now i'm going to bring the new one to
the car because it's going to tell me to
bring the new smart key
to the car so
let's just take those smart keys out of
the car now put the new smart key into
the car
okay put the new smart key in the car
it's in the car
so now it's communicating
with the car switch the ignition off
within 15 seconds so hit the ignition
one two
to turn it off switch the ignition on
within 15 seconds hit the ignition one
two
the lights come on and dash okay
then it says switch ignition off so
the ignition's off
switch the ignition on within 15 seconds
so i hit the start button
two times
is the security light extinguished yes
it is
there's no light on the dash for the key
so we're good to go
so right now hit yes the light is off
so hit the off button
then it says switch the ignition on one
two
program success so now the key is
programmed to the vehicle right now
so now we're gonna check it right now
since it's programmed i'm going to
disconnect it from the bottom
and turn the ignition on and try the key
and it works see
it's good to go now i'm going to try it
now
to see if it starts the car because the
other key is far away
so now i'm gonna hit the ignition to
start it with my foot on the brake
and the car starts and i'm good to go
it's that easy how to add a key
they definitely made this a lot easier
for the newer cars the newer acuras and
stuff and it has the acura logo on the
back which i put
and this will be um
the new key for the mdx
and extra all right i wanted to make
this video guys to show you guys how to
use the ez
pro ez400 pro this is a super easy tool
it's really easy to use
it's less than 500 bucks it programs
wireless keys and
uh regular keys i'm going to show you
guys programming uh
the keys on the tl the older tl's how
fast the process is look how fast the
process was
for the wireless keys this works this
one pulls pin codes all of that
it's a great tool it works great it's
way smaller than the x-pad 2
and way more cheaper and it's way more
efficient
when it comes to like taking it
different places and stuff like that
because it's a lot smaller
it's less to take so if you guys have
any questions feel free to ask them with
a like share subscribe and comment
peace